alors le mois de mai a rit même si c'est
pas évident certains matins et l'été
c'est là c'est le début le mois de mai
de la saison du cinéma pour hollywood
notamment ont rejoint tania ou est
traditionnellement tania ce sont ce
qu'on appelle en anglais les black bass
tous les gros films les grosses
productions dans les eaux dont profitent
de ce moment là il ya aussi des films
québécois depuis plusieurs années qu'on
essaie de lancer l'été alors ça sera un
combat en tout cas un choix un autre
choix important cette année
ouais la saison estivale au cinéma
s'amorce dès vendredi de la semaine
prochaine donc le demi avec
l'extraordinaire spider man et au québec
mais si le film de denys arcand qui va
ouvrir le bal le 15 mai et donc
s'enchaîneront de multiples films qui
vont tenter de gagner la faveur du grand
public parce que par le passé crazy bon
cop bad cop luis et ont tous obtenu
d'énormes succès aux guichets
grâce à cette saison où les gens sont
davantage disponibles et où les gens ont
envie d'aller voir du cinéma
donc qu'est ce qu'on doit surveiller cet
été autant du côté américain que
québécois et bien je vous ai préparé un
survol pays ou si vous vous je vous lis
je me suis entretenu avec des
distributeurs qui nous dise quelle est
la stratégie pour justement tiré son
épingle du jeu face à hollywood on
écoute sa bonne fin de semaine dernière
24 m
de l'extraordinaire spider man 2 à x-men
jourdain à venir passer tourné à
montréal
les super héros auront la cote cet été
encore au cinéma hollywood mise sur des
valeurs sûres
tom cruise dans un jour sans lendemain
ce salon dans les sacrifiés 3 et
angelina jolie dans maléfique une
relecture de la belle au bois dormant
face à cette compétition féroce le
cinéma québécois tentera de se tailler
une place avec les stratégies déployées
par les visiteurs sinon isr c'est
évident qu'on veut toujours être numéro
un c'est évident que les semaines ou des
films principalement une sorte c'est
plus difficile d'espérer l'être mais on
peut faire de la contre-programmation
même son iphone numéro un au box office
on peut générer des recettes importantes
quand jonathan tout j'ai eu une histoire
avec une fille c'est normal le ring de
la beauté par exemple prendre à la fiche
la même cette semaine que godzilla les
films séville mais sur la notoriété du
réalisateur denys arcand et celle des
acteurs eric bruneau marie josée croze
et mélanie thierry
autres productions québécoises à
surveiller la petite reine avec laurence
leboeuf
le film inspiré de la vie de geneviève
jeanson devra donner des résultats
rapidement faux g et emmener le plus de
monde possible le premier week-end et
après c'est le bouche à oreille trois
façons son choc son bout de chemin que
ça va continuer si on est pas capable de
le faire le premier week-end s'est
terminée le fumeur dans deux semaines
trois semaines c'est cruel
on n'arrête pas le progrès parce que
trois quatre jeunes veulent se lancer
valdes les distributeurs et dépendant du
québec tenteront aussi de tirer leur
épingle du jeu en diversifiant l'offre
la gagne les hors la loi par exemple le
24e compte pour plus d'europe de mercier
sera distribué par k films
son président louis dussault soutient
que certains distributeurs québécois se
nuisent entre deux films québécois qui
sautent le même week-end il se
cannibalisent et il ya le ray qui va
l'emporter sur l'eau tous les deux vont
sortir affaibli ça sert personne
est-ce que ça va se produire ça cet été
j'espère que l'on a on a des gens
l'enseigné audap nous certaines sorties
de films ne sont toujours pas fixés
notamment 1987 la nouvelle comédie de
ricardo trogi avec jean carl boucher
reste à voir si la saison estivale
réussir à sortir le cinéma québécois
d'une période difficile je pense que le
vent a tourné et avec la qualité des
familles qu'on doit cette année moche
que ça va continuer
magnifique intro parmi les productions
québécoises qui tenteront de gagner la
faveur du grand public cet été le vrai
du faux
avec stéphane rousseau c'est pareil
comme un film américain avec des
québécois ben nous avons aussi sonia
lapointe portrait du canada montréal
nous poursuivons la discussion sur le
cinéma le cinéma québécois évidemment
monique simard présidente et chef de la
direction de la sodec dons soit
maintenant soir alors oui tu as bien le
disait ça a été des années difficiles on
l'a beaucoup beaucoup dit et vous vous
dites moi je veux augmenter la part de
marché des films québécois et je pense
j'ai dû doubler la part de marché
oui à la fin de mon mandat de quatre ans
mais comment comment fais tu l'écoutés
d'abord la part de marché je voudrais
vous avez fait référence à des films
dans le reportage
c'était il ya presque dix ans dix ans
c'était avant l'explosion du numérique
avant les cinémas maison avant les
netflix et ses pouvoirs que
l'environnement dans lequel on vit
aujourd'hui c'est à dire est un
environnement de multi écrans on a
longtemps fonctionné avec la télé et la
salle de cinéma ça finissait là
aujourd'hui on a une multitude d'écrans
une seule façon d'avoir accès et en plus
bien une offre de produits qui est
incomparable
alors il faut tous tristes heures dans
ce contexte là quand on parle du cinéma
québécois alors par du cinéma québécois
on se regarde dans ce cas on se désole
mais moi je regarde aussi tout ce qui se
passe dans les autres pays pour voir est
ce qu'on fait si mal
est-ce qu'on est si mauvais on se
compare
c'est à dire que on travaille sur un
tellement le petit nombre de films au
québec 20 à 25 par année que sydney
on a deux trois films surperforme ça
fait distorsions dans les statistiques
et les verts c'est tout si vrai c'est à
dire que ceux sur lesquels on misait
pour faire gros achalandage v6
fonctionne pas le tout d'un coup les
chiffres tombent donc pour faire très
attention
j'ai aussi entendu le commentaire d'un
distributeur qui dit faudrait mieux se
synchroniser pour la sortie la stratégie
moi je suis plutôt d'accord avec ça
parce que entre nous il n'y a pas
beaucoup beaucoup de distributeurs qui
distribue du long métrage québécois
et il faut et donc dans ce sens là il
faut savoir que une meilleure
coordination favoriserait parce qu'en
passant tous les films québécois sauf
exceptions sont financés par des fonds
publics
vous avez dit il ya plusieurs écrans
s'intéresse à je montre un tableau très
rapidement le gros gros gros succès
louis cyr par exemple 473 mais l'entrée
ça ça veut dire qu'à quatre cent
soixante treize mille personnes qui ont
payé un billet sur une période assez
longue donc quand on compare ce que la
télévision et d'autres peu faim il faut
aller chercher presque 1 heure les
téléspectateurs enfin les cinéphiles
c'est une fois les boys 165 gabriel 150
écoute on a parlé de gabriel le saluer
voilà ce merveilleux film il ya cent
cinquante six mille personnes seulement
est-ce qu'il faut se dire le monde a
changé c'est pas nécessairement dans une
salle de cinéma mais un genre de
d'abonnement sur des acteurs tout le
monde
tout le monde me dit bon moi je ne crois
pas à la mort des salles de cinéma je
crois que les gens vont continuer
d'aller dans des salles de cinéma mais
que vont-ils aller voir dans des salles
de cinéma là la question doit se poser
et je pense qu'il faut une valeur
ajoutée pour que les gens se déplacent
parce que sont l'europe de se déplacer
payer un ticket cetera et vous de rester
à la maison de regarder tranquillement
chez soi par un abonnement mais souvent
la plupart des gens vont rester chez eux
de regarder sur leur écran magnifique 3d
etc etc donc la valeur ajoutée c'est de
plus en plus partout où on va dans le
monde on se rend compte que ces deux
mêmes défis alors il est des films d
block busters dont vous parlez qui sont
des films a trait au budget avec des
effets spéciaux incroyables
soit dit en passant dont beaucoup seront
faits à montréal par 10 watts ici que
mon nom un tiers à la londe et ça ça
vaut pas la peine de voir ça sur une
télé on manque vraiment l'effet qu'ont
et qu'on cherche dans par contre
d'autres films peuvent être vues sur
d'autres écrans et tout autant apprécié
je pense qu'il faut calculer non pas
seulement maintenant box office le
succès d'un film
il faut pouvoir le regarder en
finalement en nombre de personnes qui
ont pu le voir
sur un écran sur un autre et il ya de
l'avenir pour des salles de cinéma je
regarde par exemple des phénomènes comme
l'opéra au cinéma vous êtes filmés
l'opérant dirai ça marche partout les
gens veulent se déplacer pour être
ensemble pour voir le jour nets d or qui
sont rediffusées en est la réalité bien
chelsea qui est des exploitants tiers
qui dit ce qu'on pourrait servir de
l'alto travaillant un peu l'offre s'est
il faut travailler faut être inventif et
au québec on a d'excellents cinéaste on
a des films extraordinaires le choix à
cannes cette année le trouver ailleurs
en un succès critique qui est vraiment
remarquable pour le petit nombre qu'on
va rester en terminant conclusion faut
arrêter de se flageller aussi au fait ça
va pas si mal
puis il faut penser à l'avenir il faut
penser à l'avenir faut être inventif
faut être créatif et se dit virage
numérique qui explique l'explosion des
plateformes et bien il faut les prendre
à bras le corps à bras le corps onexim
or on voit que vous êtes bien en selle à
la sodec
merci d'aller le voir merci mal à
résister au revoir